hey Josh its Andy here and you are Josh
okay said hey Andy I played the witch
all weekend is did you probably um
here's the thing my character build
sucked for me and I was trying to figure
out why and I want to make a video that
show people some tips on what not to put
them their points in so they don't have
a kind of load time he'll experience as
I did because I kept dying and the load
times on ps4 are kind of long so I spent
you know hours of my weekend sitting at
load screen maybe that that long but
still it's art um one thing I did is I
put a lot into alchemy because I wanted
to roleplay I'm gonna be the guy that is
really good at urban ISM and stuff and
build potions and bombs and I knew the
first mutagen you get from the Griffin
was Green which as we can see when you
pop up the character screen it help it
helps know the colors because they're
color-coded you put so I didn't realize
this too a while yeah you put the
mutagens in these diamonds and if if you
have abilities that line up with it you
get like a bonus to whatever there I
can't change anything is in a fire I
will just fight so yeah I would
recommend not putting things into into
alchemy maybe only one or two because I
didn't have that good of a time when I
first started I kind of like these ones
they seemed like the best like overall
bonus yeah anyway yeah
alright we're looking at your character
right now yeah you've got I went heavy
into signs in combat yeah so talk about
safety signs I feel like you didn't use
I feel like it's paying off to go into
the signs a lot like that's the one as
I'm playing the game or you're becoming
more and more valuable what are you like
use the signs to kind of like control
your enemy and then just do the damage
with your sword so I started doing the
fire one and I haven't really been using
that one so much I've definitely been
using their like telekinesis one a lot
more often now okay so if I could redo
it I would have saved all these points
put them in here and maybe done some
more in combat what if I told you
there's a way to respec i was not aware
of that yeah it's it's one of the things
that comes up in the bottom of the
loading screens but doesn't tell you
where to go it doesn't tell you exactly
what it is just a lot more loading
screens
maybe that was one of the benefits of
dying it was like hey yo yeah I'm
playing on dresses like second easiest
difficulty you're playing on the harder
one right yeah but but I'm kind of a
outranked by my stupidity uh so go open
up your faster oh I guess you're in
scale go right now things are gonna nova
Grodd over grad there go to the bridge
maybe st. Gregory's bridge it's at the
North yeah yes it's down this path and
then you're gonna take a left there's a
bunch of merchants up here we can't buy
stuff from them they're just color
merchants like background merchants
trading called merchants but if they
aren't looks back here anything no I
guess it's just an alleyway don't see
that merchants sign they just popped on
the mini that's a nine yeah and I think
you can only go to them you know during
daytime hours and they closed the night
in something check out where we are on
the map so if you read his sign he says
merchants um but what's confusing is in
the tooltip it says I think it says
something about herbalists have this
potion oh it certainly does that in the
strategy guide that we have around the
office it says herbalist have this
potion they didn't bother telling you no
it's actually this merchant he's the
only one I found so far I went to all
the herbalist I could find they didn't
have its potential for this guy if
there's two I searched all over oxenfurt
for this potion because herbalist are
generally who have liked the potion
upgrades and stuff like that that's
right but like I don't think you can
build this potion okay just right you
just buy this potions yeah it's a
one-time use consumable okay but check
it out see that green bottle with skull
on it what this down down down
oh for a stack or a stack of G's one G
you can buy it uh who Annie's got nice
saddlebags
holy cow alright I'll buy both of these
oh you oh you rich boy okay all right
now you can respect you just go to your
inventory and use it or well that
consume boom okay let's check out my
steps
this is fun oh yeah
holy crap yo 29 you level 19 you're
pretty far okay Gojo what we want to do
is a stamina build all right let me use
a bunch of signs right yeah do you say
so
and okay I have Griffon armor so I
definitely need this medium armor boost
alright because each piece increases
sign intensity by 5 and stamina region
by 5 so that's four pieces that's pretty
sick one point yeah and so I want this
for sure because I want to be able to
always be casting signs okay cool
increases adrenaline generation and then
using signs generates points so that's
good
this so if I have adrenaline and use a
sign I should make a point and then
using this if I'm out of adrenaline I
can cast that yes so that's kind of one
of those like they build on each other
alright so I've I find one of these is
good because it's really knowing when
you got an arrow far away all right so
I'll throw that over here and then I
kind of just want to put a ton into
strength and quick oh wait well so
that's crossbows let me show you the one
on all the way over to the right so this
will reserve a drone points if you're
going for a stamina adrenaline I think
that comparable and I feel like more
often than not with the way that I'm
using signs I do that to stun so I don't
need to get a quick hit in I do the
strong one so what I want to do is just
like really lay into strong attacks damn
alright and then I think this could be
cuz I only have three slots for strength
so yeah so you might as well these ones
are all about my stamina build so I
think I should go into here but then we
also need to save some for signs we got
twenty
so you're alright alright so let's just
make sure I want ax e is so good against
my series Scoggins humans - yeah it's
not good against a group right cuz those
only does one and then I haven't been
using this nearly as much I want it go
you're knock my forces - if there are
horses oh yeah you hit the horse and it
just kicks him right out and then it's
one shot it's a down shot all right
actually I should probably cook some of
these so we know we're getting I might
just be like I've got all my things I
might have to just like upgrading like
this is pretty much it and then I just
like upgrade the hell out of them all so
I thought I was supposed to be able to
cast a sign on my standards down you
have to have an adrenaline flame thing
oh so those are empty points right now
yeah they have to turn red and I I don't
know if you'll get killed on one shot I
don't know if you'll get a lot of a
drone from these low level oh you got
one from him so you can double joint
yeah cool so again so was it worth it
wasn't worth it Josh I mean yeah
especially like when you're using AK C
against like a hard monster you're just
kind of like shining it together yeah
and then if you do get hit like that
might give you an opportunity to I think
it's pretty cool I think I'll keep this
set up all right it's definitely more
like defined a little before I had no
idea what I'm doing I still kind of
don't but like at least have a theory
jesting a direction a goal yeah it's
cool took like you go in at fresh you
don't know what to do you're kind of
just doing it as you feel and then you
realize you've messed up so you got a
respek I wonder if there's another
respect well you guys um I don't know
where it is I'll keep looking yeah